[Musik]
das kriegt über sollte und über start
nötige schweizer frauen sagt spanischen
alter sohn jetzt dass sie sich nicht um
die finanzierung
sämtlicher
teammanagers ist
[Musik]
es ist schwierig eine frau zu finden die
vor der kamera über geldsorgen nach
einer trennung spricht claudia d will
anonym bleiben das thema ist scham
behaftet aber ihre geschichte ist
typisch
sie ist mutter von drei kindern das
jüngste ist zwölf sie hat sich vor acht
jahren von ihrem mann getrennt eine
traumatische erfahrung auch in
finanzieller hinsicht
spielt voller panik seco 20 prozent und
zischt es gab
fünf grad ii muss so gesamt liche
kontext die hacker zugang mit couch ist
eine gemeinsame konnte ich hatte
eigentlich mit unterstützung von der
familie plus fokus des runden tisches
und kind neue schuhe oder york gebucht
hält
ausrechnen
was was brauche ich
claudia d hat sofort nach der trennung
ihr arbeitspensum auf 50 prozent erhöht
und verdient er mit 3500 franken im
monat
das scheidungsverfahren läuft seit sechs
jahren ist
eigentlich immer ehrlicher überzeugung
dass wenn er nicht wieder zurück sie ist
nichts als intellektuell eher einfach
immer wieder
sie sind
alle schon gegen das buch
zusammen mit den anwaltskosten hat sich
in den acht jahren seit der trennung ein
schuldenberg von 75.000 franken
angehäuft
nicht alle frauen begeben sich in der
beziehung in eine solch große
finanzielle abhängigkeit
[Musik]
corinne und yanick brecher sind ein
typisches junges elternpaar
aber im gegensatz zu 70 prozent aller
familien kümmert sie sich zuhause ums
geld
beide arbeiten
jan ist goalie beim fc zürich
und corinne arbeitet 60 prozent
selbstständig als finanzberaterin
die letzten jahre oder sie dem
russischen markt vom finanzamt plant er
das geld braucht und sie hat ihn kümmere
aber ich glaube mit so vielen wo sie
sich andere teenager bau dieser völlig
logisch dass top frauen auch immer mit
dem kümmerer und da sei aber extrem
wichtig ist ich kann wirklich
aufhört wo sie mit einmal vorne noch
etwas was daran verdient und sozialplan
ich mache also ich meine stimmung
störten gemeinsam planten wir
nicht nur um blauen wie
kinderbetreuung sondern wie man das
finanzieren
und yanick brecher haben immer offen
über geld gesprochen und ihre finanzen
bei der heirat zusammengelegt
familienkonto wo collisi kommunen rund
ums kind und
sicherlich viel brauchen wie sie wird
wie nervig das haben auch klar größere
investitionen dass das domradio sprachen
miteinander
sie hätte so dass sie nötigen wir jetzt
will sie motorisch und so weiter dass
sich eines haushaltskasse hat und ich
klar während arbeits dann immer vor so
die dritte schüler war natürlich sehr
wichtig aber weit gefehlt
komplett und jetzt
besonders hohe maximalwerte
gestellt sie ist zum detail und sehr gut
die pkk als
tochter lisa geboren wurde hat sich
corinne selbständig gemacht das hat auch
konsequenzen für ihre altersvorsorge
das sind die politik die kritische
zahlen dann mitunter mit pensionskassen
als man muss sich die 21 07 und normale
bis für die überhaupt pk hat dann ist
gott bitte wie die dritte fühlen oder
sichern mit mir sechs prozent pensum an
das aber kann ich nicht der
6800 irgendwas pro jahr sollen es ist
für mich nicht möglich sei und warum
fühlt er mit osten auf das haben wir so
vereinbart und ich sage jetzt mal im
jahr ist das 50 50
ja
das ist mir bewusst dass ich so lange
dass ich dass ich wenig geschlafen
daraufhin den reduzierten pensum moment
bitte bitte bitte
die wenigsten wissen so gut bescheid wie
corinne und jannik das heutige
sozialversicherungsrecht ist darauf
ausgerichtet dass die familie
zusammenbleibt
kommt es zur trennung haben die frauen
oft das finanzielle nachsehen wenn sie
sich vorher nicht darum gekümmert haben
[Musik]
barbara anleger ist seit sieben jahren
geschieden ihre kinder sind zehn und 13
die kinderbetreuung teilen sich ihr ex
mann und sie hälftig auf sie wohnt in
einer dreizimmerwohnung für 1500 franken
und arbeitet 50 prozent als
handarbeitslehrerin
also ich habe mir vierter sieg über und
die zuschauer nach hinten zu lassen
450 also mit
30 franken
was sie brauchen
verschenken aber für also die
steuerungen und durchleidet havelland
kenne
mich mit freundinnen und
mit kind habe sich leider von den
kindern verschiedene die krise
und die kosmetik das konnte einfach also
es ist ein knopf überhaupt nicht und ich
fahre jetzt gilt es gegen würden sich
die kosten für die kinder übernehmen sie
und ihr ex mann heftig
unterhaltskosten an sie zahlt er nicht
mit acht
prozent wenig m50 und den ich das siebte
buch komme und darin im alltag
vorwoche kind getötet im
selbstverantwortung war der 51 jährigen
schon immer wichtig geld hingegen nicht
fahrsituationen
korrektheit sich den fertig und die zwar
nicht mehr die zähne und
barbara anliker und claudia d zwei
frauen zwei verschiedene situationen
eine gemeinsamkeit beide haben sich wie
viele frauen für ihre finanzen nie
interessiert
ganz anders corin brecher
als ich sie vor sechs monaten zum ersten
mal treffe ist sie schwanger mit ihrem
zweiten kind
[Musik]
in ihrem elternhaus wurde immer ganz
offen über geld gesprochen
das hat ihr interesse schon früh geweckt
foto andrea sid ich mir sehr oft
oxidischen unternehmensfamilie xiii
magisters läuft und beim irischen sie
bezahlen in der vater verloren in europa
bestimmt ist
doch sie und laxey und haben größeres
vor anderen börsen und bankkonten
gesperrt wie immer hat das lokal unter
anderem zugang zum gang und das ist nur
so oder und darum glaube ich ist es
besser gemacht haben wir diskutiert
es ist eine möglichkeit um roth hat oder
eine beteiligen und die machen
corinne ist betriebsökonom ihn geworden
und berät heute explizit frauen in
finanzangelegenheiten
mit webinaren blogs und einer kolumne in
der annabelle will sie erreichen dass
vor allem auch junge frauen sich aktiv
um ihr geld kümmern
sie besucht ihre freundin lea ihr hilft
sie im moment bei der finanzplanung mit
[Musik]
der
diskussion
die global 100 strategie gemacht
mit der aktie
über die letzten 15 jahre hat sich
anlegen tatsächlich gelohnt
verglichen mit geld auf dem konto hat
sich geld angelegt in fonds mit 100
prozent aktienanteil um 260 prozent
vermehrt
frauen bevorzugen immer noch sparkonto
gegenüber meinem depot
liegt ja viel weniger oft miteinander
und ich meinte unterschiedlich massiv
also ich denke sich ganz klar
wieso gesellschaftlich bedenklich wenn
die schweizer
defensive
erste mal wo sie vom genannt gegründet
und das ist das ist schade dass ich ganz
gut aber
ich verstehe aber die frau war weil sie
so schon relativ sich um viele sachen
kümmern dass sie dann auf den mann als
der richtige partner unterstützt sie
damit sie ihr ziel erreichen auch in der
werbung wurden und werden immer noch vor
allem männer angesprochen
wenn es ums geldanlegen geht
und er begleitet sie bei all ihren
entscheidungen sowie die raiffeisenbank
wenn es um ihre finanzielle vorsorge
geht wir kennen unsere kunden und können
sie darum auch ganz persönlich beraten
und betreuen lea hat sich kürzlich
verlobt und ist mit ihrem partner in
dieser wohnung gezogen
schlafzimmer
und sich total ruhig
kritik noch nicht genau es aber wahnsinn
so wittwer dann ist er sich eine
möglichkeit der
konkubine tisch zum teil
der familie
das kind
vom konkubinat rät corinne kategorisch
ab solange lea verheiratet bleibt ist
sie tatsächlich abgesichert trennt sie
sich sieht es aber anders aus
und dann herrscht einfach als problem in
die pensionskasse und nach der vorsorge
und dann muss man quasi das
steht finanziell
will langfristig
also wenn der teppich noch riesig und
das
kind und produziert noch 40 prozent dann
bis b2 40 prozent
das macht dann wirklich so viel los dass
heftig und 42 prozent oder einfach fällt
42 prozent hätten eher weniger allein
bei der pensionskasse über die ganze
altersvorsorge gesehen also mit der av
wären es 37 prozent
soviel altersvorsorge haben frauen im
schnitt weniger zur verfügung sofern sie
nicht von einem mann finanziell
zusätzlich unterstützt werden ich konnte
sehr späte jungen angefangen die jungs
motiviert und schlussendlich in der
beratung von frauen mit 40 + co findet
einfach wirklich probleme frohsinn also
sprich dort das wo soll man sich
gedanken macht ja 20 jahren merkt man
locker wird größer und dann natürlich
und das ist schon
acht von zehn frauen sagen im alter sie
bereuen es dass sie sich nicht mehr um
ihre finanzen gekümmert haben
das muss sich dringend ändern findet
helena traxel sie ist
gleichstellungsbeauftragte des kantons
zürich und führt regelmäßig an
verschiedenen schulen und
ausbildungsstätten workshops für junge
frauen durch
heute an der uni zürich
ganz ganz herzlich willkommen im namen
von der fachstelle wir machen die
workshop regelmäßig freunde euch
vorstellen warum warum sind da ganz kurz
ganz mutig sie finanzplan zukunft und
das war mit der zeit schaffte nirgendwo
so
irgendwo in eine glückliche
finanzkrise sind viele frauen es muss er
hat gesprochen frau es muss frauen und
finanz unbedingt kundig machen was
bedeutet das eben in sachen lohn in
sachen
sozialversicherungen spvg häufenden
dritte schüler und einer wieder nur das
stört technisch was heißt genau so in
der lage waren gut verdient machen
investment die nachhaltigkeit die
nachhaltige fonds halte die ganze
palette von
finanz- und sozialversicherungs produkt
auf dem radar unbedingt die hand schon
vorbei studie durchgeführt wo nur das
modell sieht rechnet sich
86 sehr kurz modell aber wirklich
rechnet 40 77 also waren ihre chancen
hand mit dem partner oder der partnerin
aus handle wie viele landschaft rote
meer 70 das in der sozialversicherung
für technisch unbedingt das wissen
wieder ge kolleginnen und kollegen und
das auf handel sind romantisch verliebt
ist wunderschön bis über beide ohren
verliebt sie und danke die richtige
person am inn city und karat so wichtig
ist in dem moment sagen hey aber egal
wann das je machen machen wir das
zusammen und waren die männliche partner
nicht wirklich ja sagen sich es ganz
ganz feste fleckeby ahlen verliert sie
ob das richtig ist zum hinterher
überlege zurück und sagt da weiß ich gar
nicht ob ich das mit dem weg wie ich mir
drin bleiben und gesamtgesellschaftlich
bewegt sich müht man sich miteinander
mehr engagieren können und auch druck
machen
augen auf bei der partnerwahl und 70 70
arbeiten ist also das mantra von helena
trucks
wie sehen denn dass die studierenden
für mich ganz klar dass fischer
studierte fakturieren
100 prozent
mit anderen weg gerät wo immer sachlich
sind ja aber deine karriere und kind
also muss die schule beten
also es ist ein spannungsfeld das
möglich ist aber auch schwierig zu sagen
ich komme aus einer konservativen
familie modell
ich will das nütze aber
gleichzeitig
nicht ständig besetzt mit vier prozent
schaffen
das wie noida
das
ist schon relativ
investiert was man als morgens
unter diesen akademikerinnen ist der
wille weiter im job zu bleiben und
familienarbeit zu teilen groß aber die
partner zu teilzeit jobs zu bewegen ist
schwierig
ich habe tatsächlich mit meinem partner
weil er in der wissenschaft bleiben
möchte und das ist es gibt wenige
beispiele von professorinnen die hier
ist es um die kinder kümmern und
noch weniger sind meistens die die
frauen die sich um die kinder kümmern
und sie hat mir einfach nicht vorstellen
und
das sind tatsächlich noch einfach
handeln also ich habe immer klar gesagt
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass ich
100 prozent mich um kinder und haushalt
kümmere und er möchte eigentlich auch
sich mit um die kinder kümmern aber weiß
noch nicht wie das einbaubar ist und
sind jetzt noch weit spielen
warum wir machen dass kolleginnen und
kollegen ja also ich bin da schon
gewählt wirklich dieses 70 70 zu
verlangen weil ich mir es eigentlich
nicht vorstellen kann dass ich habe
jetzt einen partner der schafft 100 und
eigentlich sogar noch mehr ungefähr und
ich kann mir es nicht vorstellen unter
diesen voraussetzungen mit
[Musik]
solche forderungen hat claudia d wie die
meisten frauen vor dem kinderkriegen
nicht gestellt
an die schwierigkeiten die sich aus
ihrer romantischen unbekümmertheit
ergeben könnten falls sie nicht gedacht
sehr schwierig
so die ganzen einig sind und es sind
meine freunde wichtig
der holländer nach deutschland viele
wahlhelfer und
logisch dass ich mir selbst
energie auf schafe von der alltag für
die grund sie kurz und verkennt
wen kümmert's weniger der finanzen gerät
mit über 80 prozent geschafft ich habe
eigentlich nie sagen
und das hätte ist gelandet
damals hat sie sich nicht überlegt was
wäre wenn die beziehung auseinander
gehen würde
andere familien
die immobilien und
bargeld aber wenn ich zu viel bedeutet
ist das für mich als
problem sich sp maxx megatrucks dass ich
als kaufversion familie
ich treffe barbara anleger wider sie
versucht seit einiger zeit mit upcycling
von jeans ihr eigenes business
aufzubauen
ihre kollegin olga müller hilft ihr
dabei
als profi für upcycling ach ja und
ich habe männer schwierig weil ich nicht
nach und legt sie die ganz fertig machen
und
braucht einfach 2010 habe aber immer
gesagt durch die hälfte schon im kopf
hat naja aber das hat eine braucht wenig
standorte volker h ein bisschen mal eis
gegen die csu
politikerin im frühling
marijana schwierigkeit mit dem beat im
ganzen oder
pofalla
olga mila ist finanzberaterin wie
corinne brecher auch sie ist
selbstständig gibt kurse für frauen und
hat einen geld blog auf watson
finanziell angewiesen auf dieses
business ist barbara anlieger nicht
solange sie 50 prozent als
handarbeitslehrerin angestellt ist
anders sieht es nach ihrer pensionierung
aus
ich bewundere gegen die gleichheit und
auf der andere seite
warum interessiert die dann mit oder ist
die kita sieht aus wie
viel europa werde dann überhaupt die
beruhen wie ist das mit der
pensionskasse weil ich das einmal hübsch
gestorben was grund auf mich zu das ist
glaube ich alles was ich das probiere so
was herz legte willie auch sehr viel
brief wonach er sagen oh gott hätte ich
das frühjahr ist ich weiß eigentlich was
passiert ich weiß es nicht wir werden
über group aber ich weiß dass ich nicht
für besucher
ich habe immer mit wenig klappt und mir
ist wohl so
und ich weiß nicht warum man sich jetzt
im auto mir ist die kenne ich
glaube es ist eben mehr nach ostern
würden
höher zum später habe ich gar nicht weiß
lücken in der altersvorsorge sind bei
geschiedenen müttern oft ein problem
jetzt will das bundesgericht bei
scheidungen zudem die
unterhaltszahlungen an die frauen
streichen
das neueste urteil hat viele
diskussionen ausgelöst
barbara anleger allerdings findet es
völlig in ordnung
die bereits zwei menschen
und wenn man kinder möchte teilt ist der
dort auf viele frauen 20 der opferrolle
sie hantieren
50 kopf wird quasi für kind und
das und findet denn ja dass der markt
und hier bei dem tat rolle und das ist
ein irrtum ist nick heidfeld muss sich
nico womit um klinisch dollar das ist
nah bis unter das hast du wirst
handlungsunfähig nicht vom fleck und
wird ständig die
selbständigkeit und die eigene
verantwortung das lieben übernahme auf
es gibt für alles rund um den
schulversuch spricht man wenn man die
kraft kommt
und
ja ich habe ein teil von mir ist total
bitter barbara und ihre user und ein
anderer teil habe ich natürlich
verstehen wenn beide die gleichen
chancen zu im beruf fuß wasser oder bei
ihrem bruder fand ihre existenz video
sei
absolut völlig pd aber wenn aber jetzt
musste gemeinschaft sowie eine rolle
übernommen hat und das ist toll
der ganze haushalt manager die ganzen
ins männern steht damit völlig der award
schnelle füße und damit mehr korrigieren
ihre unterarme freitag dann ist das wie
viele interviews goslar das wäre dann
schwierig wenn dann der manche preis so
und jetzt muss egal ob mann oder frau
ganz genau du hast ja nicht einfach
ausschalten intrigen wunden stellen
das bundesgerichtsurteil zwingt die
frauen zur finanziellen
eigenverantwortung
und wird in manchen familien für
diskussionen sorgen
auch bei den sozialversicherungen werden
die frauen weiterhin selbst schauen
müssen bei den anstehenden revisionen
versucht man zwar mütter besserzustellen
lösungen für eine berücksichtigung der
familienarbeit sind aber keine in sicht
[Musik]
olga müller war 15 jahre in der
finanzindustrie tätig und hat für die
ubs diverse gender studies gemacht nun
veranstaltet sie finanz seminare
speziell für frauen
ich hoffe stellt das dass frau begrüßt
die bedarf haben würde jetzt mal sagen
uns belegt dass sehr viele frauen
heilige hand über gehalts rede sehr viel
freies gefühl hansi besitz wenig tribut
obwohl das auf der faktor vielleicht gar
nicht so ist aber gefühlt und sich
deswegen
getraut und dass ich auch sehr viele
frauen wie so ein bisschen ausgegrenzt
fühlen also magath dann mit ein und
ausgang und dann wird immer nur mit
einer person dreht das ist so wie wenn
sie zum autohändler gönnt und der
autohändler erklärt motor im detail
und ihnen dann fahrt vom auto das
fehlende wissen ist eine sache wenn man
geld hat aber es gibt auch viele
menschen die ende monat gar nichts auf
die seite legen können ich glaube da hat
schon sehr groß sie demokratie
digitaler es geht das will ja mancher
mit sehr wenig geld räumt anlage die gps
beispielen in ids scheer größter franke
ein fondssparplan rund 250 franken pro
monat also da gibt es beim micro spagat
mit off runde vorzeitig das nordische
oder
die tholi beratung und der ganze see bis
der hat mir wirklich ist über wenn wir
das gewisses vermögen
hat ab heute jeder wagen möchte die
therme nova krempel und av investieren
wenn ich ausgehe
ohne gewinngarantie natürlich aber es
ist im moment die einzige möglichkeit
sein geld anzulegen wenn man sich wie
die meisten menschen keine immobilien
leisten kann
das geldanlegen vor allem für kleine
jungs wichtig ist wird in der werbung
klar suggeriert
[Musik]
schön wer mit dem sparen wieder neu
beginnt und eine wand sagt wir machen
mit
eigentlich fahre mit dem taschengeld
gelb oder da gibt studie darüber dass
kindlichen alter weniger taschengeld als
kleine jungs und das zieht sich dann
natürlich türe
übertönt bis hin zum nachteil der
lohnverhandlungen für eine sieht anders
verhandelt aber andere sieht anders war
knut advance behandelt und dann zieht
sich das natürlich die ganze finanzielle
lebenszyklus touren bis hin zur
pensionierung
dieses modell zeigt während ein mann
wenn er die ganze zeit 100 prozent
arbeitet sein vermögen von einer auf
sechs millionen steigern kann verliert
die frau wegen geringeren lohn auszeit
wegen kindern kleineren pensum nach dem
wiedereinstieg und fehlendem investment
meistens geld und landet im minus falls
sie nicht verheiratet bleibt und vor
geld ihres ehemanns profitieren kann und
zwar ist halb massiv in der ahv
und versagt auch die mindset relativ ist
dass man unsere eröffnet dass die
inhalte momentan mit frankreich
machen was habe ich noch etwas könnte
die schweiz aber im moment wie seit zwei
mal so viele fragen vorortes armut
betroffen als männer investieren hat das
nicht alles für flick aber es hat
zumindest im internet verschaffen
rachel beutler ist auch eine der
kursteilnehmerinnen sie hat vor einem
jahr geheiratet
[Musik]
und natürlich sympathisch wenn wir schon
ganz viele fahrten im haus
bewegen machen und
sie gehört zu den wenigen frauen die vor
der heirat mit ihrem partner abgemacht
haben wie es finanziell weitergehen soll
wenn kinder kommen
diskutiert
einige sachen arbeite mit diskutiert das
gespann hat mannheim ist das album
herunter und das war
das machte sinn
jetzt bin ich meine punkte und 7 70
prozent zu vorher muss lange und glaube
dass ich nicht das glaubt man wird
vorher ist das
[Musik]
feuer und leidenschaft
das stimmt es ist er hat ganz viel
verging ihm
altersarmut
ausständig ist lange geschafft und nicht
für sich selber volks und r
die 65 jährige roth hoffmann die die
jungen im webinar eindringlich vor
altersarmut warnt ist verheiratet und
hat immer voll gearbeitet
sie gehört zu einer generation in der
selbstbestimmung schon möglich war
warum haben trotzdem so viele frauen in
ihrem alter geldprobleme
also spiele ich die bewegt die zielkurve
wohngemeinschaften und hebt bezieht und
verbindlich antibabypille und handwerk
ausprobieren und in der wohngemeinschaft
hat nach einer günstig wohnen und mehr
hat will ich nur als billige vermutlich
künstlerin wurden und es ist so viel
kraft sie und bewegung ob es gar nicht
das thema hat das darf jetzt grenzen
ruth hoffmann will die schuld auf keinen
fall den männern zu schieben
sie sagt aber klar
im gegensatz zu den frauen recht es sich
bei den männern viel weniger wenn sie
sich nicht um ihr geld kümmern und jetzt
meine ich wirklich toll wie gut die man
so vielleicht tritt der hand streichelt
ausfüllt und gut meinen vier männer sind
über das alter von frauen informieren
die könnte ich soll ja für meine familie
wirklich vor guter mann ich sorge für
meine familie gut nur hat heute niemand
mit garantie dass mit einem wirklich
zusammen ist alter geht unter unter
partnerschaftlich gute bedingungen und
es stand 7
ohne böse absicht
schlechter gestellt
was müsste denn politisch geschehen
damit die frauen finanziell nicht mehr
schlechter gestellt sind
ich glaube dass mir als systembruch dass
man das ganze auto zuständigen viii
reformiert also ohne jetzt vor dem würde
die haut profitieren will zukunft so hat
das nicht fragen mal dahin gestellt aber
die jungen leute glauben die unternehmen
aus vorsorge system grund und ja immer
mit privat galt alle gewusst dass seine
zukunft wie es
braucht einfach eine radikale reform und
ich glaube es braucht endlich für den
berufseinstieg
vor allem für frauen vor allem für hätte
die frau und das weiß er willkommen
damit zumindest virtuell dass in dem
kind koran doch
erwirtschaften
claudia d hat es geschafft wieder auf
die beine zu kommen
sie arbeitet mittlerweile wieder 60 bis
70 prozent und würde heute einiges
anders machen ich habe vielleicht
weniger
offen ich war mehr im profener probe
hd-fähig fordert
vorlieferanten auf familien übernahm
ich bin aber froh
ist dass grund zur trennung das steht
der schreck machte und mehr
verbindlichkeit noch viel größer sind
jetzt mit 49 sieht es in hinblick auf
ihrer pensionierung alles andere als
rosig aus immer man zu wenig - vor so
oliver k s zogen ist das sehr wenig sind
das 800 bis 2000 franken also vor dem
haben was ich eigentlich dass ich
zu den frauen die in etf soder bitcoins
investieren würden wird sie aber auch in
zukunft wohl nicht gehören
corin brecher hat vor acht wochen ihr
zweites kind bekommen und bereitet ihrem
wiedereinstieg vor
in einem coworking space hat sie
genügend ruhe und distanz vom
familienalltag
ich bin jetzt
vorbereiter für die zeit wenn ich dann
mit der
vorfall so viel heißt prozent
vorgenommen die firma hat kommentierte
wochen einfach die heißt das aktuelle
tief früher schon wieder mit e mails mit
social media präsenz mit völlig dass ein
interview
gleichzeitig mache was ich habe ich
mache nie so gut wie nie fühlen
und alles andere kommt dann zb tiefpunkt
die ökonomen gibt schon kurz nach der
geburt wieder richtig gas
rohstoffsteuer wurde dann für ihren plan
abrücken und sagen
ja ich habe absolut nachvollziehen ich
bin auch wieder wonach sie bei mir ist
dann aber relativ schnell wieder
zum zirkus offen und waren jetzt der
wunsch nicht und dann muss ich sagen
muss man einfach am strand ortega und
dann für sie neue organisation machen
ohne dass ich alles schlief er
jetzt mache vorbereitungen für den
online kurs im herbst startete sind
videos und
herzlich willkommen zum zweiten modul
wir hatten im ersten modul uns die
verschiedenen ets angeschaut und auch
die verschiedenen indizes viele
anlegerinnen vor allem frauen ja sagen
dass sie angst haben um ihr geld und das
ist absolut berechtigt
deswegen weg altersvorsorge zu sein
investiert
schöne choreo tiere mussten noch mehr
und das ist neu aber es ist ein fakt
dass das geld auf dem konto
wirklich weniger wert weil ich
wirklich das ist einfach
inflation gut für mich sagte die
nachbarländer sind schlimmer dran als
bio ist
das geld von utah wert und fragen was
macht man damit
der börse ist es halt so dass man
einfach nur die figur die chance hat
trudel
horizont ev
auch die banken haben mittlerweile die
frauen als potenzielle anlegerinnen
entdeckt allerdings spielen sie dabei
auf abgegriffener klaviatur du
investiertes vermögen in style und
diesel adrianos links la liga sie für
friedliche idylle drei attraktive
renditechancen
während koch in arbeitet betreut ihr
mann jannik die kinder
der macht das das weiß in der musik also
dass wir alles gemeinsam für die kinder
entschieden
und dann gehört da dazu dass er sie in
capital hat was ich als sehr wichtig
finde das ist nicht zu mommy lustig ist
an der uni zürich weist helena traxel
die studentinnen auf die stolpersteine
puncto vereinbarkeit hin auch wenn viele
studentinnen gleichberechtigte modelle
wollen sie zu leben ist schwieriger als
man meint
triba krw und privates in der schweiz
dieses thema
nach gelandet wir haben unnötig gute
infrastruktur in child care in
kinderbetreuung abgebot wunderkind der
hand 0 entgelt für betreuungssachen das
hängt immer noch mehrheitlich der frauen
0 kind sondern kranke angehörige ich bin
vor noch nicht so lange zeit
amerikanisches referent den ganzen
anderen
public affairs manager zusammen und habe
mir den markt fachlich stelle ich
brauchte war das integrierte gestellt
meine geschwister mit unbezahlten
betreuungsarbeit hat braucht zwingend
wie stelle ich mich nie so groß sagt
sind bemalt jetzt eine exakte zahl halte
darüber klagten die und inhaltlich sei
theologisch es macht mich traurig seit
jahren ihre eltern es ist ein traum ja
klar ich meine ja auch immer profitieren
familien cryptic sie sind jetzt geht's
gut also die selbstverständlichkeit über
reus frei zu verfügen das ist mein
zurückzahlen
aber nicht nur männer denken in alten
mustern auch frauen haben ihre bilder im
kopf
ich glaube dass
ich fast alle frauen nicht ganz ganz
fest frank tisch dass das mutter sie
koppelt sich mit einer karrierefrau
könne sie und mir fühlt sich immer
schuldig warmes wild und da muss man
muss kein partner verlange und sage aber
du musst mit haus und zwar mehr als nur
der die 20-prozentige tag also ich will
dass du wirklich dritte 33
geschäftsleiter der eibisch probiert das
am arbeitsplatz darf verlangen heißt er
wird sagen controller kinect mir alleine
und dass mir das nicht aushalten dass
man das für einen einer person tank das
gruppe der frauen hat modelliert mich zu
nehmen oder die gigs einige wurden noch
gibt und dennoch verloren die
ängste sind ganz ganz vordergründig da
das muss nicht macht der erotik und wir
machen sehr viel beratung ist immer noch
gängige muster frau gesagt am
arbeitsplatz nicht und man sagte heine
und der markusplatz und den hannes
schöner teil doch gab es sie macht er
alles und er macht geschafft alles und
ich glaube dass das muss aber dazu sagen
dass auch frauen der us werk doch auch
gern hand dass ihr wahl hand sie fixiert
aber der bitte mal dass die krawall hand
beruf oder privat ist sie zu gast und
sagen ja nun also der job als manager
tätig tritt die mannschaft müsste mir
einen anderen null zu machen
kilometer heim kapazität wintertag das
heißt er muss der minero system drin
bleiben aber wir sind in mehrere teile
der mutterschaft gleich betreut wenige
schaffen mal lädt vater dann muss er
gastfamilien
claudia d ist wie viele andere auch in
diese rolle gerutscht nun endlich nach
achteinhalb schwierigen jahren ist die
scheidung durch
sie ist erleichtert
es sieht gut aus
und
unterhalt vom staat erhielt die meere
für mich okay ich bin eine langfristig
autonom unterwegs muss mich nicht
rechtfertigen
claudia de hat sich vorgenommen eins
nach dem anderen anzugehen um ihre
altersvorsorge kann sie sich erst
kümmern wenn sie die schulden bezahlt
hat
ich halt garden im moment nur dass ich
alles
sollte
ziele ist und dass ich
denke das ist dass man hier können
[Musik]
corinne und yanick brecher geben sich
mühe nicht ewig gängigen muster zu
fallen
doch mit ja nix job als goalie ist das
gar nicht so einfach er kann keinen
fixen tag übernehmen um luisa und
maurice zu betreuen
ja das hat auch unregelmäßig das ist die
meisten sagen such unterstand manz
jahren normalerweise prominente oder
ältere aber dann fotos gesagt meistens
mir oder so wie mir und und knistert es
ja ich klar der sieger geschafft werden
klar eigentlich abdeckt und familie oder
weil dann die krippen abdeckt sie und
wenn es dann unter der woche man spontan
sich da gibt es dass sie neuartige und
ich werde nachmittag frieden haben das
meistens auch so flexibel auf die suche
oder ein buch hervor wie das möglich ist
er sei sehr glücklich dass man so eine
treuhand
großeltern und motor nach der schlacht
größer weil die arbeit gezeigt und ich
hab das sind 8 milliarden pro jahr wo
die großeltern der familie norden führen
das müsst ihr zahlt sie
bei den anderen familien in ihrem
bekanntenkreis leben die meisten bereits
neue familien und finanzmodelle
von mir persönlich verbinde
meine kollege plus kollege von mir sagt
ich kann jetzt keiner wo
sage es mal so das klassische spiele
frau hat warf de wartet diesem punkt
training unter macht
viel frau beruflich macht fit sind und
ich glaube die schweizerin der
solidargedanke
source programm bis fünf ski plus - und
dann weiß nicht was dann passiert bis
dann für die nummer genie auch ständig
und sehr gut dass das ist so aber
noch weiß niemand wie die zwei korea
gestartet und ich hoffen aber die
endlos das mobilitäts reformieren habe
profitiere von dem brief wird dann auf
jeden fall noch mikrofone müssen
profitieren
[Musik]
vielleicht ist das alles auch einfach
eine generationenfrage
hoffentlich kommen jedenfalls möchte
nicht nur für sich eine gute lösung es
ist eher eine herzensangelegenheit dass
alle paare anfangen über ihre finanzen
zu reden
ich wünsche das ist eine
gemeinsame es auch recht gemeinsames
projekt das man öfters überträgt
selbstverständliche und das ist
eigentlich das tabuthema wie ich will es
nicht und das brauchten dialog und das
muss gemeinsam auf gott will bald lernen
ganz ganz viele
[Musik]